hey you guys it's movie retrospective
time this time around we are doing a
movie I had actually never heard of this
movie even though it was from the early
80s this was sent to us by one of our
listeners Rob of out of time pictures
yeah Rob Levinson he's like a director
yeah
and interestingly it's like it's like we
kind of always talk about movies and I
thought that I had kind of seen
everything from this era just because I
watched so much cable and [ __ ] like that
but I had actually never heard of this
movie even though it was written and
directed by the famous Michael Crichton
yeah he did a lot of good ones that I
liked you know he did Westworld and
demon seed one of my favorites and
dramatists promised rain watch album
coma coma but I haven't seen that one
I haven't seen that one yet I haven't
seen a long time but I remember really
like I had seen this one but forgotten
about it why I was convinced I was kind
of confused about what year it was I saw
it in yes watching this and I remember
this one this is the one that had gene
Simmons running around shooting people
with a light gun that would mesmerise
yeah yeah right I conflated runaway
which is also much as I thought Michael
Tommy right yeah and that one had gene
Simmons running around shooting people
with a damn pistol of fired guided
missiles yeah the light gun was from
this light with gun was from this one
but I never did forget I never did
forget forget that light gun and like
the way they edited those scenes yeah
because in the day that was a futuristic
concept
Michael Crichton I have to say I'm you
know obviously he's best known as a
novelist but he directed a lot of movies
as well um I feel like a constant theme
that kind of runs underneath his books I
mean they're mostly like science-fiction
thriller-type things it's always kind of
like science run amok type of thing yeah
but I do feel like a lot of his stuff is
really um it's prophetic yeah it always
happens yeah the story's about is about
basically using computers to scan models
and then the
can CGI them into commercials without
having to reshoot it and then they can
judge people's responses to the videos
and make the perfect the perfectly
manipulative emotionally manipulative
commercial yeah do we have that today
it's called CGI it's called algorithms
and 3d modeling 3d modeling the same
thing pretty much all of that stuff and
like even like the retinal scanning and
all that gross stuff that is very
commonplace nowadays yeah and it wasn't
but it was funny because they're trying
to make a movie about it with a bunch of
core of corporate power involved with it
trying to put kind of a sinister spin on
something that's basically kind of like
it's kind of like a movie about laptops
my god we all have laptops well he was
saying is we watch that we wanted the
movie once through like and then because
I had never seen it you saw it a long
time ago yeah and then we watched it
through with Michael Crichton's
commentary so he was kind of talking now
I think this was the first movie that he
directed after Westworld
so this one out of all his movies this
seems the closest to what actually ended
up happening I mean this seems the most
believable obviously it came out in 1981
so the technology is very dated like all
the computers are like big [ __ ] brim
sighs [ __ ] and like all the robots look
like little squares that go all the axis
although a demon seed could now happen
at any moment
singularity with computer consciousness
and then it's just [ __ ] I'm gonna use
nanites to impregnate a woman so I can
download my consciousness into a human
being instead of being inside this
trapped inside this computer I mean it's
they're talking about that kind of stuff
now but I'm kind of saying that look er
this movie this what happened this is
actually kind of happened because now
they can I mean obviously like I said
the technology they used at the time
like for scanning the models and stuff
like that they just had to use like he's
like we just had to use this something
that looked cool because you couldn't
actually do it at the time you know with
just these kind of like light little
crosses and stuff like it was kind of
like taking in all her form and then
mapping it yeah but she's kind of what
the movies kind of like a moot
murder-mystery that's kinda like a cop
flick yeah because that's like because
like I said I really I had not heard of
this movie like I said obviously I heard
of Michael Crichton I've seen most of
his other movies but I had never heard
of this one somehow it kind of went
under my radar and the wait so I didn't
have any idea what it was about I didn't
read the blurb on the back or anything
like that because I just you know like I
said I can't I kind of like to go into
stuff like cold without knowing so like
you said the very first part of this
it's bit it's very intriguing because
it's set up like a mystery I mean
basically what you have I mean you have
a thing at the beginning where it's just
like this really cheesy ass commercial I
think it's for that [ __ ] the one for
the perfume yeah right called ravish I
think it's all do it it's like telling
you put it between your toes like it's
it's like cheesy but it's kind of like a
real commercial from that time it's
really not that weird the movie the
whole movie is a product of its of its
age it's it's being futuristic I think
this is what 80 81 81 okay well this
this this movie is just 81 is [ __ ] it is
yeah but it's kinda actually futuristic
for 81 it looks a little bit more like
84 85 in terms of decor yeah so it was a
little bit ahead of the curve but it is
it will eighties the [ __ ] out of you
just a you you know if you grew up
during this area era
you'll recognize furniture and and and
and you'll recognize like wallpaper
motif patterns holy crap I remember that
that the the models apartment at the
beginning yeah like this super pepti one
it's like so pink and like there's
mirrors everywhere and mirrors and
chrome everything yeah everything is
like just chrome and like pastel colors
and I was sitting there thinking man
it's like that part of the 80s I really
hate it and I even hate it at the time
because everything looks very sterile
and very if you wore it if you're into
like this pastel like pinky gray and if
if you're into like dead moth videos and
like urban exploration
channels where they're going into like
abandoned hotels from a long time ago
you'll see that this is what those
hotels and look what they look like when
they were in yeah because it's creepy to
see that [ __ ] now and abandoned
oh it's kind of creepy granola grown all
over it near but you remember how kind
of low quality everything was in terms
of construction it was almost like
something out of the Soviet Union it was
cheap and it even kind of looked it
looks sheep in retrospect I don't really
think about it at the time but like I
said this is kind of like it's set up
like a murder mystery because basically
what happens after this little look like
weird like fragrance commercial at the
beginning is that there's this plastic
surgeon who's played by Albert Finney
who is actually like a big deal actors
he was especially like known as a
theatre actor but he was in tons of
other movies as well very well respected
he's in this as a plastic surgeon named
dr. Roberts and he's noticed that these
this handful of women who are models
have been coming into his office wanting
plastic surgery but they have a list
that's very very specific that it's like
you know I need my nose like trimmed by
two millimeters and I need my boobs like
done by this so they have this like
really and he's like sitting there going
um you're arty good-looking so what's
the deal like what good is that gonna do
yeah yeah these women man they bring
back the 80s as [ __ ] to me too as a kid
you know I mean I just remember when
they were just skinny as [ __ ] it was
that first model Oscars they were all
tall and skinny yeah and they looked
okay from the front you turn around a
back man you were flat as a board to
[ __ ] him no booty just like straight up
and down with like a slit going up the
top for a crack and they just poke hard
type tight looking women the first one
bad hair yeah only the one from The
Partridge Family was really cute isn't a
yes she's the only one that would be by
today's standards to be considered cute
yeah the rest of them were I just forgot
how extreme yeah that model look was it
was not good-looking
Susan day was thin but not like so thin
but because the first model that's in
this she's not actually an actress I
think she was just like a Playboy model
yeah and she's kind of the first one to
get killed or whatever and they have
like scenes of her like walking through
her apartment and she's really tall I
mean she looks really tall I don't know
if that's just the shoes but she looks
like she's at least 5 foot 11 and she is
merely pounds fed very and I've just
forgot how extreme models looked back
there like I was obviously taken aback
yeah yeah and really they had a bunch of
them and I guess they were they were
good-looking women in the contact by the
standards of the 80s of the context of
the time they all had that same real
super skinny just kind of just there's
just something about them they just
weren't they were not sexual
and sometimes the fashions back then
didn't help to [ __ ] like the lingerie
because remember those underwear yes
like suede yeah I be going like a
walking visa they were supposed to like
in theory they were supposed to make
your legs look longer I think this way
but that was not what it just made us
look like about two feet tall like your
Aspinall back yeah big old tall tall
tall narrow flat ass it did this [ __ ]
didn't work back then it really didn't
anybody who was thinking about I don't
know who's thinking that looked good
well I don't know but like I said that
was just kind of the style because I
seventies looked better they had better
lives because in the seventies like
everything was kind of like rested on
your head yeah they had hip huggers they
had them which looks better bell-bottoms
with the tight around the hip scenaries
big on the legs which actually does make
your thighs look similar yeah like yeah
well because it balances it makes you
look more shapely you know I mean yeah
but late 60s and 70s fashion was better
I think they realized that the 80s was
it was just so like a lot of it was box
like it was very Soviet it was very like
you know what I mean it had like these
really like dramatic angles I said the
underwear like went like big shoulders
huge shoulder pads that made it like I
couldn't wear that because I have wide
shoulders anyway and it's like so I just
looked like a big goofy hair a
ballplayer walking on this yeah weird
hair yeah he's so much air spray my punk
rockers looked good my hair wasn't that
big but I did like the spiky bangs yeah
but I had like half my head shaved and
stuff like that only punk rockers looked
good in the eighties pretty much yeah
like all the all the kind of like a
corporate
because I hated all those like pastel
colors and everything was just like so
yeah
boxy but the movie was good though it's
it's the Edit is kind of slow about a
day standards and even the director so
pointed that I said it was just a sign
it was just the way where it wasn't the
times and it was I didn't notice it back
then people took their time watching the
movies like you're really seeing some
[ __ ] yeah but you see it now and what
impressed us back then just doesn't
impress people now yeah you don't dwell
on it
and yet it's a lot faster he did make a
point that there's one particular scene
where the doctor Larry Roberts he's
played by Albert Finney and Cindy who's
one of the models because I didn't
mention it before but the models that
have been coming in like asking for
these really specific like fixes they
start ending up dead they usually like
fall out of windows and stuff like that
oh and I have to note here this movie
has one of the best stunts yeah I have
ever seen in any movie ever
this chick falls out of a - [ __ ] chick
falls out of a window probably five
stories up and lands on her on her back
on the hood on the one that's my car and
it smashes that roof down in and her
legs and her knees fly over behind her
ears I mean it's almost kind of like
she's going down on herself or something
just BAM folds her ass in half and then
she's a low motion slow motion and then
she goes flying up off the car just
lands on the ground and that was a real
stunt woman really did that in lingerie
and lingerie he's wearing like a little
lot like a Teddy or something like that
and the top of that car just explodes
all the glass block blah stops I saw
that and I was like it looks like it
killed is that one okay I was like
bagging today and I watched this other
route I watched a couple other reviews
this there's not a lot because I guess
this isn't kind of an obscure movie but
one of the guys said that he but he said
the same thing he's like oh my god that
was the most amazing stunt ever and he
tried to find out who that stunt woman
was but he couldn't find out who it was
but I the other review I saw that called
that where her legs called it vagina
stuck yeah she just folded her right up
it was amazing
never seen anything that stunt is as
impressive as the stunt at a road
warrior where the guy comes off the
motorcycle and is his legs clip the
railing of yeah one like that and like I
said the fact that is just like in the
middle of the frame and they show it in
slow motion in her damn damn near
see-through nightgown yes she just
weren't a little short night got a
little panties all the time I was like
crap it was really you could tell it was
a real person that that was not a dummy
you know just you could see all the
jiggle even though she asked any to
that's it that's the thing it's like
whereas don't touch that car look like
it killed her yeah I was like I was like
how does she not break everything a bone
in her body I mean maybe they I don't
know I was sitting there thinking could
they have like softened the car somehow
but it didn't look like it no they just
said they just knew they just knew that
there was how to fall
they knew that the roof of a car could
absorb quite a bit of clearly and I
don't know she fell five stories no I
doubt it the way they shot it look like
did you but when they showed the impact
she must have probably at least follow
us to from quite a height 20 feet
probably the way it looked real it
looked like somebody falling dog I'm
sorry Linda and I was just like my mouth
fell open
she had to have jumped off you know like
20-something feet because it busted all
the visor you are lady holy crap good I
salute you it was good that was badass
I've never seen anything like that yeah
so all that all the models are showing
up dead and they're in there armed
they're trying to frame the the plastic
surgeon the doctor working on them and
it's weird how they kind of show it you
know you don't know exactly how they're
being killed but then they show it later
on and during another homicide there's a
dude with this damn black plastic light
gun it looks like somebody's play laser
tag with yeah and he points it at her
and pulls a trigger and it uses a
pulsing light that somehow [ __ ] up
your nervous system it knocks you out
you just stand there like a zombie for a
minute or so until you recover and
during that time they can do all kinds
of stuff to you yeah cause it sets you
up and get ready to push out a window
like I
not really sure how long it worked
because when they did it to Albert
Finney's character like later in the
movie like they flashed him with the
light got a couple too and then he was
like standing there in like two hours
had gone by yeah so it makes you lose
track of time I don't know if it's like
I think it was actually manner I think
it was only a few minutes but I think
that dude was there with him that all
over over and also when he started to
come but then he started to come to I
think he would SAP him
yeah to keep ECB's just kind of keeping
him keeping him unconscious with it and
and that's like one of the one of the
one of the what he caught one of the
gimmicks of this movie is this damn like
gun yeah and I remember when I first saw
it the effect is pretty good for the
time yeah I mean for 1981 like I said
it's dated obviously but yeah and then
whenever they use it it kind of showed
and it changes hand the good guy gets it
for a while and well actually actually
he gets one of them he cuz they attack
you there was more than one of them
because I think the bad guys came out
yeah I think they all had one yeah yeah
and like weird [ __ ] would happen like
you would forget that if they were
behind you in a car and they shot at you
that it would reflect off the rear view
mirror and get you yeah so there's all
kinds of cool things the fight that's
like one of the funniest things and from
listening to Michael Crichton talk um I
will say that it's like this movie it's
like play pretty generally I'm James
Coburn is in this too by the way he
plays like the evil bad guy like the
head of the corporation or whatever
which is called digital matrix but um I
think that he meant some of it to be
satirical because some of this stuff is
kind of funny like and I think it was
meant to be funny like it's just like
the the car chase between the doctor and
the goons and they're like shooting the
light guns at each other it's just like
yeah yeah there's no recoil er and
there's no sound yeah it's just like
there's just like really funny and then
like I guess and they're all trying to
like cover their eyes and the light
doesn't get in there and then like
albert finney like he like it gets him
and then they just should they just cut
to his car like in a fountain
yeah he's somehow made it anyway he's
somehow like ramped into a fan or
anything and it's like when we were
watching the the director commentary cuz
I said well the cops are there and like
the
in the fountain and you can see like in
the grass there's tire tracks but
Michael Crichton was like you know he's
like when I watch this movie now he's
like there's really no way that car
could have got it he's like I was like
basically said [ __ ] it like I don't
think anybody really knows I noticed I
noticed that car getting I did yeah but
I think the way that car I think he met
people back then didn't really notice
yeah there's no way to ramp over that
damn ledge yeah because there was
nothing there it was like grass like a
park and there was like a sidewalk at a
fountain what a crumpled that car up
yeah because the car was just like
sitting perfectly like in this fountain
so there's like kind of some but the
reason that I'm saying that some of it I
think was meant to be funny or meant to
be satirical is the last sequence where
because like I said essentially what
this digital matrix company is doing is
they're making 3d renderings of people
so they don't have to like so they can
have them perfect because I think one of
the things was that you know they wanted
the models to have these particular
proportions and that's why all these
girls were coming into the plastic
surgeon to get all this stuff fixed but
they said that when we did the tests on
them
it's like while they were standing still
their ratings were very high but then
when they started moving around people
like didn't like it so it's like they
decided to just like take the
proportions and then just like animate
them themselves so they could do
whatever so they have this big studio
that has all these different sets on it
for different commercials there's like a
kitchen set and a bedroom set and [ __ ]
like that
the way they imagined CG happen and it's
not the way it really went down but you
could tell the way that they directed
this set up it's black with all these
damn illuminated lines like green lines
yeah like a goodness you can see that
Star Trek and knock next generation rip
that off for the holodeck yeah and it's
kind of like the holodeck in a way
across doing the holodeck in a and a TV
station yeah because it's like yeah and
they brought they can actually film in
there and broadcast it live and
everybody on television
sees the the the real images of like the
furniture and then like the CGI people
superimpose the order and then if
somebody runs to the set
see them too yeah which that's plays
into the movie so that's like the last
sequence is a movie that's why I'm
saying I think that was meant to be
comedic obviously because there's stuff
like you know one of the goons get
killed and he's like in the middle of
like the dining room table and then
there's like a commercial where there's
like all these little kids like it's for
cereal or something like that there's
like a dead body in the middle all the
shareholders are watching this watch a
demonstration you know of what the
technology can do it's it's a very
corporate movie the tone to me was kind
of like a cross between Robocop one and
Halloween three you know how that's
pretty accurate
I think that's pretty accurate yeah cuz
remember having Halloween three he's
doing into his own investigation into
what the hell yeah the silver shamrock
cut yeah this is kind of like kind of
like that but it's a lot more I wouldn't
say believable but a lot of higher
budget yeah imagine it being kind of
like happening in like demon seed or at
the level of demon seed or Westworld or
you know what else did he do that's like
that but it reminds me that the tone of
the movie kinda reminds me of a cleaned
up version of Halloween I said yeah I
just one of my favorite movies is it's
not really a horror movie
and I would call it a sci-fi thriller
yeah because it's more like a mystery
and then like it goes off in this weird
sci-fi direction I was listening to this
podcast earlier and it's this three guys
I think it's called film illiterate and
they were talking about this movie and
they talked about it at length for like
an hour or something like that
and the one guy that was on there like
one of them really didn't like it he
just thought it was dumb and silly and
everything the other guy was really into
Michael Crichton and he'd read like all
his books and he loved this movie and he
said that he's like this is the most
Michael Crichton II of all of it he's
like this is the most like a Michael
Crichton book like the way that his
books are written this is the most like
that I think it was kind of an important
movie because you can see some of the
ideas that were lifted out of this and
used in another series and the sad thing
too is that this movie was actually the
first movie to use
3d shading with a computer and also the
first to try to make a realistic 3d
computer-generated character
I feel like Tron gets all the accolades
for that but this actually came out a
few months before Tron but I guess
because this movie was not successful
it was critically panned and I don't
even feel like most audiences bothered
with it it has some problems first of
all it does the and it's too slow the
story isn't very movable the leading man
isn't a real convincing action hero if
you ask me
yeah well and there should have been
more action in it yeah who would have
been better in this movie at that time
who's that Arnold Schwarzenegger I don't
know daggoo he doesn't seem like a
plastic surgeon well you had to go over
the top kind of goofiness you know oh
you know like a stuff you know I mean
the light gun hey no no he gets him the
light gun he's blinking you know okay
now that would have been fun yeah he
should have done it kind of the tone
with the tone of like Homer he goes to
Mars Rico yeah should have had like the
tone of Total Recall
yeah because more action stuff this is I
mean like I said it's not it's not
overtly funny I think some of the comedy
comes from it just being so dated cuz
like you know what I mean it's like they
tried it they're trying to get into what
it's called the looker lab because like
the looker is like looker is um not not
only talking about like the women being
good-looking but it's also like an
acronym for something that I can't
remember like wait what is it a light
ocular oriented kinetic emotive
responses that's right yeah oh yeah so
that's what it's for so it's like they
they're trying to get into the lab and
it's like they stole a key card from
somebody that works in this place but
the key card won't work on the liquor
lab because I guess that's like the
super secret super duper secret lab but
somehow they get in there because they
hitch a ride on a janitor robe
which is essentially just a big square
yeah like a cube thing on on a track
that just has like two two little arms
that pop out the side and like empty
trash into itself yeah so they just like
sit on it because that janitors give
little janitor is going into the looker
lab and there goes handy and I'm like
well that's not very good so I take a
tease robot though and that's kinda what
they look like in warehouses today yeah
it looks kind of like little little
maybe Star Wars robots and square ones
with like little wheels on them and [ __ ]
but this didn't have a face I'm like
that danced like a little box I remember
I had when I was little big tracks big
track was build vehicle with a bunch of
keypad on the back and you could run
around shoot lasers and [ __ ] I don't
think we asked what level the robots
were at and then yeah at this time much
like you said you can't [ __ ] on it for
that because it's like that's what
people thought robots would be like I
can get you in the 80s and it's just
like let's have this big huge robot that
goes around the whole building at a
track and just like dumps trash because
it's too much trouble for a person do it
yeah now one thing that people have
complained about and I didn't really
notice this until I heard of the people
talking about it there are actually two
cuts of this movie the the cut that's on
the disk that we have is the theatrical
cut but there was also a TV cut that had
that was longer and it had like more
scenes of exposition now in the TV cut
there's actually a scene explaining why
digital matrix started murdering these
models because in the movie really does
they don't explain it now see in the
movie I was just thinking um they need
them they wanna pay they didn't need
them and they don't want to pay him
because the whole thing was it's like oh
well they told they were talking to
Susan day and they were like well once
we scan your body and we can use you in
all these commercials and stuff and then
you don't have to do anything else but
we'll pay you two hundred thousand
dollars a year which holy [ __ ] in 1981
that was a [ __ ] ton of money right and
she's like well that seems really weird
that it's like you're gonna pay me for
doing nothing and it's like yeah but
we're paying you for who you are we're
using your image so we're just gonna but
you don't have to do anything else so I
was kind of thinking that that that was
the motive well yeah that they were just
like well they'll tell you that you'll
they'll scan you and then they'll just
have you don't say they don't have
a motive that well it was kind of that
um the guy was explaining like one of
the goons was explaining that it was he
it was akin to like shredding documents
I guess so like other corporate so there
was like if there was corporate
espionage like they couldn't figure it
out or like a model couldn't go don't
know what else couldn't go celery mister
somebody there's somebody else and then
there'd be like competition or something
so I think it was something like that I
mean I just assumed that they didn't
want to pay the girl it's like so once
they got your image why the [ __ ] would
they need you anymore yeah that's kind
of poorly conceived because the Disney
Corporation if you work for them they
own your image forever yeah they don't
have to do that it would be very easy to
like put in a kitchen contract right and
that it would be you think it would be
much safer than like randomly knocking
off people with models are disposable
they've always been with like a highly
classified light gun which can scramble
your brain and make you lose several
hours at a time kind of like an alien
weapon it's just kind of funny models of
disposable they kind of come and go
there just flavor of the week so that
they don't really want your image for
very long yeah so I mean that's the
thing this movie I think it was kind of
ahead of its time in the way it was a
satire of advertising because there's
also an aspect of like where they have
the because I think the light gun is
like a variation of the [ __ ] that
they're putting into the 3d model
characters for the commercials that are
like making you buy stuff like that
yeah like subliminal messaging like it's
hypnotizing you um so they're kind of
satirizing you know advertising how
ubiquitous it was becoming like even in
1981 oh I gotta give a shout-out to the
to the gun guys who are listening the
there's only one cool gun makes an
appearance a real gun yeah most of times
just revolvers and [ __ ] you know I
submit and Wesson revolvers but the
corporate hit man shows up with a cobra
m11 917 gun that suppressed it's got a
suppressor on the front of it and it had
a side folding stock which I'd never
seen before but if I could look real
suitable if you guys know what I'm
talking about
but yeah he's hunting down the he's in
running through the corporate offices
with that mac-10 was this was that the
big meathead a guy with the porn stash I
think it was that guy was a football
player yeah that's right it was him the
football player guy yeah yeah maybe
that's why you got this movie confused
with the one that had Tom Selleck in it
cuz that guy kind of looks like Tom
Selleck except like a big I cashed I'm
Ashley the Sherman and run away together
I don't think I've seen run away either
run away we're gonna get that one to run
away I think Rob said he'll send me that
one oh okay I'll review that one to run
away was about was Tom Selleck playing a
cop it was kind of like a a Blade Runner
his job was to uh to destroy
malfunctioning robots oh I did see that
yet he kinda had armor and uh and you
know [ __ ] ray gun and well the bad
guy and that is gene Simmons from kiss
and he's got this damn pistol that
shoots guided missiles little guided
missiles or about three inches long yeah
yeah that's it but I kind of confused
that movie with this one I think I've
seen that but I didn't remember gene
simmons being in it yeah gene Simmons I
remember correctly I mean some of you
might correct me just tell me the
audience back room I'm pretty sure [ __ ]
about that I'm pretty sure it was Gene
Simmons yeah and because what I remember
we're talking about it you know at the
time brick oh man gene citizen yeah you
know really but for some reason I
thought gene Simmons running around that
light gun yeah you got the two movies
well I mean it's it's easy to see how
that happen because they can you
probably saw them right about the time
cuz when did runaway come out 8485 yeah
but I think yeah I think I saw I think I
saw this movie in about 85 or 86 yeah
and then runaway probably right after it
cuz it was probably on cable or on TV or
HS probably and they're both you know
and they're both by the same writer
director and you probably wouldn't have
known that but like the style is so
similar connection that you would have
been a good night but I might have been
recommended me too
might have been recommended to me by
friends who knew that there was the same
director and we might have watched them
close together might have been watched
him in the same night yeah you know I'm
BHS but as soon as I saw that pitcher
run aways of Tom Selleck and then yeah
it's a picture of
gene Simmons with that gun and I
remember that gun immediately had the
magazine up in front of it the big old
long magazine like a rifle mag yeah like
a little short rifle mag of in front of
trigger guard and it shot out some kind
of damn heat-seeking missiles yeah yeah
I remember it vaguely I'd have to go and
see it again though I was gonna say I
wanted to when we were listening to the
directors commentary one of the
anecdotes that he had about the filming
of this movie just amused the [ __ ] out
of me it was one where there's one scene
in it where Susan day is she's this I
think this is before they do the 3d
model of her and they're putting her in
a commercial and they're making her like
fall down on the sand like they're
playing beach volleyball or some kind of
[ __ ] and like she's just not falling
right and it's like you know the the
people looking at the commercial or like
not responding well cuz it's like look
that angle is just wrong and blah blah
blah so they were filming this scene out
on the beach and Michael Crichton says
one of our somebody on the crew I don't
remember who it wasn't with a cameraman
or something like that he said he had a
dog I think he said it was a pit bull or
a Rottweiler or something like that and
the dog's name was pig and he said so
all the women he's like and others all
these like hot women cuz it was all
models and stuff like that they were all
in the set that day and they were taking
a break like sitting by the trailer like
eating lunch or whatever he's like I
said this just goes to show like how
women even good-looking women like
perceive themselves they're like so the
guy on the crew like leans out of the
trailer and calls for his dog he's like
hey Pig and every single woman at that
table turned around like she was talking
there's also a lot of nudity in this
movie it kind of lingers on it but not
sexual new to know it's like it's more
like artistic nudity yeah - and they're
so they're so scrawny it's not erotic
anyway because really I mean the only
time that that you see the nudity is
when they're doing the body buys games
well no there's also pictures in the
background of them and again that's
pictures of you know of them you know
that they have hung up on the walls it's
just those a lot of it I think that's
why it ended up this ended up at first
it got an R rating but then I think like
the MPA like reconsidering it just gave
it a PG they didn't have the pg-13
because the nudity is not sexual in any
way not really it's just kind of like
there or it's like I said it's almost
like more artistically done it's not
really a black meant to titillate or
anything like that it's what you wanna
call it I can't really think of a better
word clinical to me yet well maybe Clint
what is a better word I was gonna say
Medical but yeah that's kind of a
similar kind of thing but yeah this is
um like I said this is kind of a little
bit of a forgotten flick you know if
you're into Michael Crichton and if
you're into these types of like sci-fi
movies and you can deal with you know
something that came out in 1981 so
obviously the computers and stuff like
that it's not gonna be anything like
enlightened I was gonna say earlier that
Michael Crichton was laughing because
he's like you know how in the movie he's
like it was a big deal like it was very
futuristic to have like a like a key
card like to swipe like yeah that's when
it Dora futuristic and he's like so they
have like kind of a lingering shot on
and he's like obviously you wouldn't do
that nowadays because those [ __ ]
things are everywhere and it's not you
know it's not a big deal like it's not
my second anymore I remember seeing this
you know back in the day this seemed to
be a very high-tech movie yeah
but you look at it now and you're like
huh but the funny thing about the movie
is that every location is every interior
location is some kind of set pretty much
we get out of its way to be kind of
extravagant and exotic looking you look
at it now it looks like an 80s mall yeah
I think everything was built into the
scent like the models apart models
apartment videos the corporate places
the the corporate headquarters and I
think some yes set
I guess the exterior shots where it said
wasn't a set yeah and it was exotic in
the day but you look at it now and it
looked like I said it looks like a tired
old use malls and abandoned damn hotels
yeah what it looks like now I think the
only time I could that it was kind of
Jay and it's not that bad but the one
scene where Albert Finney and Susan day
are in there kind of hiding out I guess
so they're like in that beach house and
they're kind of talking in front of the
big like bay window or whatever this
piece and this like the ocean is in the
background to me that looks like green
screen
not super obviously but you can tell
that that's not really a share when she
fell off that window in the background
you could tell the skylight the skyline
looking out her back apartment wind up
in the shot everything was just a damn
backdrop yeah he said well he's dead
earlier you say was they were cloth
clawed alive Drive yeah like outside of
the windows and stuff yeah it's like it
didn't really occur to me until I was
watching it again and then saw that
beach house the beach house seemed I
guess because it was bright daylight so
you know nighttime it doesn't stand up
as much yeah back in the 80s all these
apartments and all these houses and [ __ ]
everywhere you went there's an entire
full bar and big ol [ __ ] wine racks
and [ __ ] with [ __ ] at hundreds of
glasses and you're like how many
people's this [ __ ] gonna have old
nice house you know you know you don't
know your life he's ready to serve like
40 [ __ ] people I think that happened
a lot like movies back coming over
everybody had like a human like a whole
[ __ ] store like a no yeah I remember
that [ __ ] Boomer bling you know I'm
like that must be nice it's a it's
Boomer bling I mean we I mean we drink a
lot like comparatively but it's like
even we only have like maybe three or
four bottles oh you know in the living
room at a time it's like I don't have I
don't much of booze in your house for
the boomers was kind of like a sign of
damn wealth especially I think it
actually came from their parents coming
back from the war from World War II yeah
so having these big bars in your house
meant that you were successful when you
had a bunch of friends we're gonna come
over and all the corporate friends gonna
come around you know what the [ __ ] they
want to go over your house and drink
yeah like they don't have bars and to
have clubs and [ __ ] well in everybody
you know if anybody watches Mad Men
which is like all the [ __ ] corporate
advertising offices where every [ __ ]
office had a huge full bar in it yeah I
was like wow that I mean cool now I did
used to I did used to work at a company
that you know they sold vodka it was a
vodka distribution company so they did
actually have a full bar in the office
that was like really nice and sometimes
when they got a new flavor and there
were somebody mixed a new cocktail we
get to like try it out like okay those
days are up days are over Manny's
corporate jobs now they have pajama day
and [ __ ] they [ __ ] sitting around
[ __ ] with stuffed animals and boxes
[ __ ]
if they could do that with booze and
cookies and that would be like the
perfect workday lawsuits well yeah
that's true it's somebody modern world
is sois [ __ ]
but yeah so anyway what was I gonna say
okay so like I said if you're into
Michael Crichton if you're into this era
of sci-fi thriller like I said this is
kind of cool like you know in the way
that that builds at the mystery and
stuff like that's a little bit slow but
you know I thought it was kind of
intriguing I want to buy an old Fiero
I've been less than over two fierros
some about all this eighties [ __ ] you're
showing me I saw somebody rebuilt this
kid so much I do I'm lucky 84 Fiero and
I'm going like it is [ __ ] catch fire
I want one you know okay you can get it
for like a thousand dollars well what
you changed your mind just like fixing
the [ __ ] man I'm sick of like pulling
motors of rebuilding motors and [ __ ]
fix and [ __ ] and you finish the
motorcycles yeah it was just it was just
just bringing it up it's relevant it was
you know from the early eighties early
eighties in the eighties
yeah cuz you've been talking about like
maybe getting some of those cabinet
video games and stuff yeah from the 80s
which that I think I would get more
enjoyment out of that cuz I don't really
give a [ __ ] about cars but it's like no
no no man you look at some of those
little video games that entertained you
back then and then you try to play them
down you're like what the [ __ ] is that
well I probably suck at him now anyway
cuz my [ __ ] reflexes for sure had fun
with is like what's with shinobi yeah
shinobi yeah that was pretty fun I
wouldn't mind having like joust or
something again it's something I have it
or Dig Dug
I have yeah I thought you did he's got
like old and you get bored with him real
quick
I got the whole Williams arcade yeah I
bought it for 20 bucks I guess it's
funny back in the old days I used to go
to the [ __ ] convenience store next my
grandma's house and I would play jester
like because it was in that cabinet had
the big buttons and it was in fronting
there's all lit up yeah and you're in an
arcade filled and you didn't have
anything better to do and arcade was
filled with that [ __ ] and you were 14
true you know the minute yeah yeah you
know and there and it was something
mysterious to it because you didn't know
how video games ended yeah you thought
maybe if he played him long enough
something special would happen like
aliens would come down like a Last
Starfighter and give you a job yeah
remember that never words what would
happen or something bad would happen
like yeah Bishop of battle yeah oh
that's a deep cut do you guys remember
that one that was a [ __ ] it was an
anthology horror movie horror sci-fi
something like I think it was called
nightmares I remember Emilio Estevez
being in it and I think I mean the
Bishop of battle was pretty much the
only story than anybody remembers from
it and it was kind of like that it was
like this a videogame and it was like a
3d wireframe guy who looked kind of like
destro from GI Joe and he was like
talking to news like evil and [ __ ] I'm
gonna look for that on [ __ ] YouTube I
haven't seen that a million years I saw
it like so many times back in the 80s
and I loved anthologies all right but
yeah well I'll have to review that one
if we can find it but yeah so go check
out looker from 1981 by Michael Crichton
you know if you want to go right